مشاهدينا اهلا بكم الى هذا اللقاء الذي
نستضيف خلاله اللورد طارق احمد وزير
الدوله البريطاني لشؤون الشرق الاوسط
وشمال افريقيا لورد احمد اهلا بك معنا في
قناه الجزيره تقريبا شهر ونصف الان وهذه
الحرب الاسرائيليه مستمره على قطاع غزه
نقف امام تكلفه بشريه عاليه لعدد الضحايا
المدنيين في غزه ما الذي تنتظره بريطانيا
لتدعو الى وقف لاطلاق النار في
غزه اولا ان كل حياه تفقد في هذه الماساه
هي حياه لا ينبغي ان تموت لابد ان نقول
بوضوح كل حياه مهمه ان الماساه اللي بدات
في السا من اكتوبر عندما حصل الهجوم
الارهابي على حماس من قبل
حماس اثار هذا البلد وما شاهدناه بعد ذلك
في الوضع والمعاناه الانسانيه في غزه بعد
ذلك امر فضي ولا بد ان نخلق الطريق
والمجال الكافي لوصول الى وايقاف لهذه
الحرب وفي هذا الصدد اود ان اوضح ان كل
حياه مهمه هناك اسر تتاثر بصرف النظر
كانوا اسرائيليين او فلسطينيين مسيحيين او
مسلمون كلهم مهمون وكل حياه فقدت هي خساره
كبيره ولابت التالي ان نوجد حلا دائما
لهذا النزاع وهذا ما تركز عليه المملكه
المتحده لكن بالنظر الى المعطيات واعداد
المدنيين الكبيره واستهداف اسرائيل
للمستشفيات والمنشات المدنيه والمدارس
واماكن ايواء
النازحين هل مازالت بريطانيا تجد مبررا
لاستمرار هذه الحرب متى ستدعو لوقف اطلاق
النار اولا وقبل كل شيء ان اعط المدارس
والمستشفيات نحن كنا واضحون جدا في
تعاملنا مع اسرائيل في هذا المجال كشركاء
لها بانها هذه المواقع لابد ان تحمى
والكثير من الناس ياخذون ذلك يستعملونها
كماوي لهم و من اطفال ونساء واليوم نرى
المزيد من الاطفال يقتلون لابد ان نتاكد
ان نصل الى نقطه ما بحيث ان
الوضع يكون يسمح بوصول المساعدات
الانسانيه المطلوبه هذا ما تركز عليه
المملك المتحده وايضا لاكون لدينا مجال
كافي نعمل على مثل هذه الاولويات مع دول
كثيره من ذلك قطر للتاكد هذا الفضاء
المجال اللازم لايقاف الاعمال العدائيه
الحاليه وايصال المساعدات انسانيه فالكثير
من الناس قد قتلوا وان كل الحياه مهمه
واكد لكم ان المملكه المتحده تركز الى حد
كبير على مساله ايقاف وانهاء هذه الاعمال
الحربيه بشكل دائمي وليس لفتره بل بشكل
مستدام فهذا هو المطلوب قلتم انكم تحدثتم
الى اسرائيل وقلتم لهم ان هذه المنشات
المدنيه وهذه المستشفيات يجب ان تكون
محميه لكنهم لم يفعلوا واستمروا ويستمرون
في استهدافها حتى هذه اللحظات بالتالي اي
مبرر لاستمرار هذه الحرب الان لماذا لا
تنتقد برطانيا بشكل واضح هذا السلوك
الاسرائيلي الذي يستهدف الان المدنيين
بالدرجه الاولى في
غزه اولا وقبل كل شيء لو عدنا الى ما حصل
في السابع من اكتوبر
احتياجات الناس في غزه من الابرياء
الاعتياديين علس ما الذي تحقق فوضع حاليا
يدعو الى الصدمه هذه بدايات هناك بدايه
دخول المساعدات الانسانيه وبعض الحالات
الشديده والخطر لابد اخراجها واعطاء
علاجها واذا كذلك اجلاء الاشخاص تحقق بعض
التقدم طبعا طبعا نحن بعثنا برسائل علنيه
الى اسرائيل حول ان عمليات اللي تقوم بها
ولا بد ان تكون ضمن احترام القانون
الانساني الدولي ونحن لدينا علاقات جيده
مع اسرائيل بشكل خاص نتواصل معهم لغلط
تقليل الضرر باكبر قدر ممكن فالكثير قد
ماتوا وعلينا ان نوقف ذلك انا سبب وجودي
في المنطقه وسبب وجودي هنا معكم هو
للتاكيد مره اخرى على ان هناك دول مختلفه
لكن سواء كانت قطر او ملكه المتحده
الولايات المتحده او
شركاء من الخلج اخرين لا يتعاونوا لايقاف
اولا لايقاف هذه الحرب وحيث يك هناك مجال
مستدام لوصال الدعم الانساني لمن يحتاجه
ولكن علينا لا نسى الامر هذه نافذه
موجوده في هذه ضمن هذه ضمن هذه الغيمه
الداكنه جدا
وكانها الكل هنا في اوروبا والولايات
المتحده وهنا في المطقه كلنا علينا ان نصل
حل مستدام هذا هو الارث الذي يجب
من وهذا ما يجب ان نقوم به في المجال
الانساني وبريطانيا تقول انها تقدم
مساعدات للفلسطينيين
و معبر رفح ما يدخل من خلاله من هذه
المساعدات للفلسطينيين داخل قطاع غزه لا
يشكل سوى الحد الادنى من احتياجاتهم ما
دخل طول مده هذه الحرب كان يدخل في يومين
قبل بدايه هذه الحرب لماذا لا تضغط
بريطانيا ل على اسرائيل من اجل تسهيل مرور
هذه المساعدات وصول هذه الاحتياجات الى
السكان داخل قطاع غزه وهم بامس الحاجه
اليها اولا انا اتفق
معك ان الدعم مطلوب والدعم الانساني اكيد
مطلوب واعتقد انسانيه هي ينبغي ان تكون
دعوتنا جميعا وهذا نعمل على ذلك ولو عدنا
الى ما حصل في البدايه تطلب الامر تغيرا
دبلوماسيا كبيرا لارسال هذه الشاحنات الى
عن طريق رفح وعلي عن اللوجستيات ان رفح هي
محل معبر واحد وان الطريق كان حتى قبل
النزاع كان هناك معاناه في غزه وكانت
الامور تصل عن طريق كرم شلوم من الجانب
الاسرائيلي و نستخدم كل قدراتنا
الدبلوماسيه من منها فتحه معبر ل شلوم
والل صال المساعدات الانسانيه لنحاول ندخل
100 شاحنه الى ف قبل الحرب كانت 500 س
شاحنه تدخل وكان تاتي من كرم شالوم ولكن
نحن نحاول على فتح هذه المعابر وليس ست
ادخال الطعام والدواء ولكن نشجع ايضا و
تحقق خته بسيطه فقد بدا الوقود يبعث الى
غزه لكن نتك نقاط العبور هذه وارسال الدعم
الانساني ليس لفتره مؤقته انما امر مستدام
الهيئات الاغاثه لورد احمد تعتبر ما يدخل
حتى الان قليلا جدا ولا يكفي هل سمعت بان
هناك من سيموت جوعا وعطشا داخل قطاع غزه
اين المسؤوليه الاخلاقيه والقانونيه
لبريطانيا هنا في الضغط على اسرائيل
لربما عدم وقوع كارثه مجاعه الكل بات يقول
انها اصبحت قريبه الان في
غزه اؤكد لك باننا
فعلا نوفي بكل التزاماتنا ولذلك انا وزير
الشرق الاوسط لا فض عفنا جهودنا في هذا
المجال بل نتعاون ايضا مع وكالات الاساسيه
وشركائنا الدوليين ومع مصر
ومع مع الانروا فمثلا نحن الان
نقدم 57 مليون ف نقدمها الى الانروا
ونتعاون مع ه المؤسسات اولا للتاكد من
نعرف ما هي احتياجاتهم وثانيا ل نستطيع ان
نقدم لهم الدعم المطلوب ولكن كما قلت بحق
ان يقدم الح لا يوفي بالحاجه لا نريد ان
نشاهد اي شخص يموت جوعا
قج ل فقط المملك المتحده بل كل الشركاء
الدوليين مهما كان عندهم قيم اي اضافه
يقدمونها لابد ان تقدم لانها ضروريه الان
اسرائيل التي لا تلتزم بقوانين الحرب
وتخترق هذه القوانين الدوليه الانسانيه
تدعمها بريطانيا عسكريا ماذا عن هذه
المعادله
نحن ان اسرائيل حليا تقوم بعملياتها
بنفسها ولا اعرف من اين من اين جاتي فكره
الدعم العسكري هم يقومون بعملياتهم
بانفسهم نحن نركز على الدعم الانساني
وايضا على عن طريق صداقات هنا كحلفاء
لاسرائيل ايضا نحن في موقف يسمح لينا كما
هو بالنسبه للولايات المتحده ان نبذل
ضغوطا دبلوماسيه على اسرائيل ليس فقط انه
في عملياتهم
العسكريه حمايه المستشفيات والمدارس اتفق
معك ما نشده من معاناه غير مقبول هذا يكسر
قلبي ليس كوزير في الحكومه بس كانسان
كوالد كثير من الاطفال يموتون الكثير
المدنين يموتون وبالتالي لا بد ان نهي ذلك
وقدر
يتعلق تمسك اسرائيل بالقانون الدولي
الانساني فهم دوله وعليهم التزامات ولا بد
ان يحترموها ونحن واجبنا ان نذكرهم بهذه
الالتزامات الهامه المسارات التي تبحثون
الان لورد احمد للتواصل الى وقف اطلاق
النار في غزه ما الذي تستخدمه بريطانيا
الان كاوراق ضغط على الحكومه الاسرائيليه
لوقف هذه
الحرب لو نظرنا الى بعض الاعلانات الرسميه
التي قمنا بها في هذا الصدد كنا واضحون
جدا
بان الوصول الانساني ليس فقط الوصول انما
الدعم الانساني المستمر وتوفير الظروف
الاخرى وكذلك اسرائيل كانت واضحه حول ح
اهميه نقطه مهمه تتعلق باطلاق سراح
الرهائن وبالتالي من المهم الدول التي
لديها الور منهمك المتحده ان تلعب دورا
وهذا ايض ان اعترف هنا الدور المهم تقوم
به دوله قطر لان ما نحتاجه حاليا هو
الدبلوماسيه الخاصه انا انا وزير منذ
حوالي سبع سنوات نحتاج الدبلوماسيه الخاصه
ليس العلنيه هو لان كل الامور تبنى على
العلاقات الجيده واكد لك اننا اتصالاتنا
من على مع الامم المتحده مع اسرائيل مع
السلطه الفلسطينيه مع رئيس عباس وفريقه هي
في مقدمه اهتماماتنا وما نقوم به حاليا
بعضها نعلن عنه ولكن كما تقدرين هناك
الكثير
من الضغوط الدبلوماسيه نقوم بها بشكل خاص
وذلك لاطلاق سراح الرهائن
وايصال المساعدات الانسانيه هذا هو ما هو
مطلوب هذه الاولويه رقم واحد وثم لا هناك
الطريق واسمحوا لي الهدف النهائي لابد ان
يكون دع نتحدث
عن حل
الدولتين نطبقه فعلا اسرائيل الى جنب دوله
فلسطينيه مستقله قابله لحياه هذا هو الهدف
الذي ينبغي نعمل عليه وان ما اشرت اليه في
ما يتعلق باطلاق السراح الرهائن والدعم
الانساني هذا يعتبر خطوه اولى مهمه لوضع
اساس لنرى الحقيقه تحقيق ذلك الهدف اللورد
طارق احمد وزير الدوله البريطاني لشؤون
الشرق الاوسط وشمال افريقيا شكرا جزيلا
لكم على هذه المقابله شكرا جزيلا وشكرا
لكم مشاهدينا على المتابعه الى
اللقاء